congressional Democrats now in control
are demanding a mountain of documents on
various topics in a flurry of letters
sent out today to 81 individuals
agencies and other organizations tied to
President Trump the president says he
will cooperate with a greatly expanded
Democratic probe into his conduct the
head of the House Judiciary Committee
says it is very clear in his mind the
president has obstructed justice yet New
York congressman Jerrold Nadler says
it's too soon to talk about impeachment
Republicans say this is all political
laying the groundwork for the Democrats
impeachment move
we have Fox team coverage tonight Brit
Hume has analysis of the investigations
and the fallout
we'll begin with chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge and the
details tonight and there are a lot of
them they are good evening Brett with
subpoena power in the gavel House
Democrats are launching wide-ranging
investigations that go far beyond Russia
House Republicans say it's not a search
for the truth but never to damage the
president through lengthy and methodical
public hearings all the time President
Trump responded to House Democrats
seeking records from more than 80 people
in entities in mr. Trump's orbit from
the White House in the 2016 campaign to
his businesses and family members we
will be issuing document requests just
to find the broad probes into alleged
corruption obstruction and abuse of
power the House Judiciary Committee's
Democratic Chairman said special counsel
Robert Miller's Russia focus is too
narrow we can't depend on the model
investigation for this the memo
investigation number one we don't know
when is ending despite lots of rumors
number two it's focused on specific
crimes the House Minority Leader
countered that the president's former
personal attorney Michael Cohen
shoulders a lot of the blame for
potential legal exposure overpayments to
silent store McDaniels during the
election if a higher attorney to make
sure I carry out the law the attorney
has a responsibility to tell me what's
right and what's wrong in the process I
watched this is a fine if it's a finance
campaign those are fines those aren't
impeachable in the process the
White House press secretary confirmed
receipt quote the counsel's office and
relevant White House officials will
review it and respond at the appropriate
time
congressional Republicans said the
wide-ranging investigations are about
20/20 and the accused Democrats of
shifting the goalposts now that they
believe the Russia collusion cupboard is
apparently bare the investigation is
changing developing right so we've been
investigating collusion and obstruction
clearly they've left that far behind
they've already written off Moeller
republicans are refocusing on the
anti-trump dossier after a Florida judge
ruled that a deposition from its author
former British spy Christopher steel can
be unsealed those records are expected
to reveal how the Democrat funded
opposition research came through
multiple unofficial channels to the FBI
in an effort to lend it credibility the
issue has already got traction in the
Senate where Republicans maintain
control Brett okay Catherine thank you
welcome